j'ai été emprisonné en fait j'étais
enfermé mais peu pouvoir rien faire ne
pas savoir où aller on avait des
restrictions donc on ne veut pas aller
loin et par manque de moyens et de
possibilités j'étais vraiment
comme dans une boîte
[Musique]
oh
et
et ces sourires
à partir de la troisième semaine on a eu
une sorte de montée en puissance de la
demande de psychiatrie car les patients
qui se sont présentées ces patients qui
présentaient des épisodes psychotiques
aigus
on a eu trois fois plus que la période
que c'est drôle tonnes en 2010 9
essentiellement des personnes qui sont
deux bases d'une structure fragile nous
des troubles de la personnalité
c'était pas des tentatives de suicide du
confinement
en tout cas c'est le confinement qui a
gravé le symptôme des patientes et des
patients qui auraient pu ne pas être
hospitalisés dans leur vie si elle est
élue ce confinement qui est quelque
chose d'assez angoissant pour eux je
passe toute la population qui a pu le
lire
[Musique]
il est certain que nous avons tous
traversé une période très difficile très
éprouvante qui a été émaillée de
séparations de deuil de stress divers et
on peut tout à fait imaginer et
peut-être encore pour de longs mois
l'émergence de troubles qui auront un
lien plus ou moins direct avec cette
période très stressante que nous avons
traversée
[Musique]
finalement ce retour progressif à la
normale qui n'en est pas vraiment un peu
inquiété beaucoup de gens il ya à
nouveau des inquiétudes autour des
contaminations
et puis simplement la rupture de
l'équilibré intérieur beaucoup d'entre
nous on a trouvé un équilibre qui était
peut-être pas parfaitement satisfaisant
mais enfin pendant deux à trois mois
on s'est habitué à certaines conditions
de vie sur lesquels il faut revenir
maintenant et ça aussi c'est un facteur
de stress qui peut on peut être induire
de nouveaux trous
[Musique]
donc on va je pense devoir s'adapter
comme on a comme on l'a fait pour la
réanimation il va falloir imaginer
moyon nous le
d'adapter le capacité à recevoir plus de
patients en espérant que derrière on
pourra pérenniser les structures qu'on
créera pour répondre à cette demande qui
je pense qu'on fera est ce que cette
période de confinement c'est une période
qui a été difficile
[Musique]